gage grosskroyd's stuck a loaded gun in
your face yes yeah
he's never been charged for that he
hasn't um
he
i told him i was going to the police and
he pointed a gun at my head
and i from what i remember time slowed
down i just remember staring down the
barrel of a pistol thinking i'm about to
die
and
he hasn't been charged with a single
crime and what's really disturbing is
that his dui case was dropped right
before my trial so
my attorneys couldn't ask him about it
and that's my belief but his his open
dui case for driving under the influence
was closed a week before my trial
does it surprise you to see him
described as a hero as he has been in so
many press accounts
i don't i don't see him as
in my opinion there's no winners in this
case there's no heroes in this case
i defended myself i was attacked i think
it's actually quite sickening how mr
huber
and mr gross groups are described as
heroes when it's on video that they
attempted to they attempted to murder me
in the middle of the streets
so what's the message you think the
media are sending by describing them as
heroes
the message i get from it is that
they're saying you can go out and riot
and attack anybody and you will have the
support from the media and the
politicians to do whatever you want and
kill innocent people and if they defend
yourself you're named a hero that's the
message i believe is being spread
scary
do you have any idea
like were you interested in politics
before this
i'm gonna get a lot of hate for this but
i was a pretty big andrew yang supporter
before all this were you really yeah
you're part of the yang gang i was part
of the yang gang
um i like yang yeah he's a good dude
but i wasn't really into politics i
didn't know much about trump
i didn't know much about biden
i just knew i went to a trump rally
because trump supports the police
he's a businessman that's what i liked
about trump yeah i didn't know much
about politics i was just a 17 year old
kid but you liked andrew yang i liked
andrew yang i i liked his policy a
little bit yeah well he's he's very
smart interesting guy very intelligent
so has this changed her politics
i don't know i i've been trying to stay
out of politics completely like no
matter what direction i'm gonna go
there's gonna be people that don't
support me no matter what so i think
it's just my best interest to avoid
politics because
i'm not a political person i'm just a
person who has attacked and defended
myself
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else